sherry is writing in talking about her
story seeing her story is too long every
time she tries to tell it and she's
having a hard time cutting it down to
the essentials so when you're telling
your story to people how do you make an
impactful without talking for too long
probably the first thing is think about
the audience you're trying to surf so in
our mention that word empathy you know
what it war problem you're trying to
sell what pain point and if you can tell
them your story reflecting against their
their needs and really speaking for
their hearts then I think here you on a
winner and then make it really simple
use languages simple understandable
compelling exciting evocative and you
are absolutely unaware i just think when
I look at you know the companies that
have been turned down for money some of
them because they probably had to refine
their stories as tons of you know like I
just mentioned big tangle teezer you
know revenues now 23 million they got
turned down another trunki our revenues
like 10 million dollars all these
companies I've been out there either a
stage where they've gone through friends
of family and you invest in trying to
raise money and the key thing was that
pitch had to be involved in shortens and
Crispin's so it is really good at the
other thing actually around this I think
it was fair to say just give them enough
of the story to tease them for the next
chapter don't try and read the whole
book at one just tease them and what you
really want with a great story you want
the forward which is whatever elevator
pitch where everyone call it but it's
compelling evocative audience sensors
and it just gives them not to say wow I
want to go to the next stage and then
the next stage of the next station and
then they owe from the rich fabric of
the whole whole book chapter by chapter
yeah just like being a good salesperson
you know the best sales people use their
ears more than their mouth you want to
get good storytellers starts by
listening before talking understanding
who they are and what they need to do a
thousand stories you can tell Steve and
I I could tell a thousand stories about
different
mark pass but it's picking the three out
of those thousand that's going to make
an impact on this person in front of you
and so if you have no idea who you're
talking to it makes it harder you can
pick your most effective story but if
you have a little bit more context than
who they are what they're going through
then you can select the right stories
from your past that will have a
meaningful impact on them so you don't
go too long and get really boring yeah
and then just a fun thing everyone that
is I always love to listen to stories to
tell me about how customers have been
successful so if you're you're at a
stage where you got some early customers
go and listen to Evan point to those
customers and they will tell your story
better than anybody could in the world
and then you want to bottle that and if
you can tell a customer story of your
prior to your service how it's changed
their lives how it's made their lives
easier Your Honor winner you're
absolutely you know unstoppable get
customers to tell your story for you